if you're a fan of the classic XCOM
series of strategy role playing games
that pit soldiers versus an alien
invasion you are in luck 2k games is
reviving the series this year with xcom
enemy unknown we spoke to developer fire
axis games about what makes the new
version just as difficult as previous
versions so if you're a fan of the
original I think you'll really find that
we've stuck to a lot of the core
principles there's a lot of stuff that's
still similar to the original but we've
grown it a little bit forward and made
some things a little bit more easily
navigable you're going to find
permadeath and destructible environments
to be pretty big we've done a lot with
that those are really core pillars of
the game and they were from the original
which are still in the game today you're
also going to find a lot of RPG light
sort of elements you level your soldiers
up you're going to grow your squad in
ways that you couldn't do an old game
each soldier unlocks different abilities
and so there's a lot of depth there and
a lot more you can do in teejah CLE
psionics is is a very large part of the
game and it wasn't the original it is in
this one what you saw in the demo we had
a soldier to control mind control and
then blow himself up there's a lot of
that sort of thing you can do psionics
that you're actually going past humanity
and evolving the human race in a way
that
normally would be able to so do we being
Santa controlled your soldiers all have
a random random qualities and attributes
them that you develop over time to
notice and one of their stats is will
and so some some characters are a little
more resistant and some are a little
less resistant to sonic attacks and some
of them develop so if you're new to X
come I mean there's really nothing like
this out there there's there's no game
that does what this game does in a
normal gameplay scenario you're juggling
growing your soldiers evolving your base
discover new technology adapting it to
the human race you're going through all
that stuff and still responding to
different missions all over the globe
and trying to keep all the all the
nations happy we're looking at a fall
2012 release on PC 360 and yesterday
you